Donald Trump has previously referred to
senator Elizabeth Warren as Pocahontas
and the entire joke if you can recall it
is that it's related to Elizabeth Warren
being some fraction Native American and
this old controversy about whether
Elizabeth Warren received preferential
treatment in admission to Harvard
University because on some application
forms she had identified as Native
American right so that's what the joke
dates back to so at the White House a
few days ago they have this event
presumably the event is to honor the
Navajo code talkers who were absolutely
instrumental in world war two if you're
not familiar with the code talkers
google it very very interesting and
Donald Trump is standing at the Oval
Office he's standing next to a number of
Navajo code talkers and standing kind of
below a portrait of Andrew Jackson which
is also relevant to the story in some
strange way and I'll get to that in a
little bit and Donald Trump decides to
do the obvious thing I guess if you're
Donald Trump which is you start slamming
Elizabeth Warren and referring to her as
Pocahontas in front of Native Americans
and almost as I mentioned almost adding
to the ridiculous nature of this if
you're looking at the picture we have up
you see that this was all going on right
below a portrait of Andrew Jackson and
recall that Donald Trump this loves
Andrew Jackson and it just so happens
that Andrew Jackson was responsible for
massive death and displacement among the
Native American community so like every
detail of this is absolutely atrocious
let's now take a listen to Donald
Trump's comments referring to slamming
Elizabeth Warren as Pocahontas in front
of an audience of Native Americans you
have very very special people you were
here long before any of us were here
although we have a representative in
Congress who they say was here a long
time ago they call her Pocahontas but
you know what I like you because you are
special you are special people you are
really incredible people and I will have
from the heart and the absolute heart we
appreciate what you've done how you've
done it
the bravery that you displayed and the
love that you have for your country is
there anything more patronizing than how
Trump is talking to this Native American
man and how he sort of Pat's him and
says despite the fact that we have
Pocahontas you I like like every little
personality element it's so patronizing
and it's what racists do right I mean
yeah right one of the good ones
you're one direction that's exactly
right hey by and large there's lots of
Mexicans that aren't rapists but they're
not exactly sending us our best we've
got this Pocahontas and also I thought
that the thing was that Elizabeth Warren
wasn't really Native American but Trump
is kind of implying she's one of the bad
Native Americans you're one of the good
ones though you I like unlike Pocahontas
it's hard to even really talk about this
because if you don't realize that this
is horribly disrespectful then no one's
going to convince you of that by telling
you what happened and why it's
disrespectful right and and aside from
the use of Pocahontas negatively it's
also just disrespectful to bring people
to the White House ostensibly to honor
them for their military service and then
to just spend the time slamming other
elected officials during the speech
meant to thank them and praise them that
that's number one of what's
disrespectful here layer two is
obviously referring to Elizabeth Warren
as Pocahontas right and for people who
don't get why this isn't okay it's kind
of like referring to someone who's
partially black as Jemima over there or
imagine like if you had a half Jewish
person or someone who identifies that
Jewish as Jewish because they had like a
Jewish great-grandmother and saying yeah
we've got we've got this real rifka
Rosenblatt here it whatever it is it's
horrifying right it's absolutely
horrifying and remember who people
remember when people used to say oh I'd
like to have a beer with George W Bush
and then when it was Obama versus McCain
there was a debate about would you
rather have a beer with McCain or Obama
as a sort of way of figuring out who
would be a good representative now I
always thought of that as really stupid
I don't think it really tells us
anything about who would be a good
president or wouldn't be a good
president forget for a second that
Donald
doesn't drink can you imagine sitting
down for a drink of any kind a coffee
its he one of one of trumps oversized
sodas I don't know what the hell that
guy drinks it would be a social
experience completely devoid of all
meaning and value period like I don't
even know what that would be like and
it's a truly vile incident and this is
just another piece of why the guy just
can't relate to anybody I'm reminded of
when he went to Puerto Rico and started
shooting rolls of toilet paper or paper
towels like basketballs like it was some
kind of game you know yeah I mean he
won't seek out to be offensive again all
these people by accident yeah it seems
to come naturally to him like I wonder
what goes clearly this wasn't scripted
right I was there and he says at some
point hey Native Americans well what
about that Pocahontas oh how could I
work that in here he's saying you're
great people you love your country he
didn't think this through and that was
the next thing that came to his mind and
the defenders are the worst
Sara Huckabee Sanders I know she wants
to go by Sarah Sanders but I'm
maintaining that it's Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she was asked about like hey you
know it seemed like a disrespectful
comment and here's a long list of people
from the Native American community and
other communities who have said hey that
this was really disrespectful will you
comment on that and she just completely
laughed it off like I think that's
ridiculous and didn't even even give an
explanation well she kept saying that
the real offensive thing was Elizabeth
Warren lying on her application oh
that's right yeah yeah
diversion tactic that's what we should
really be angry about and we should
really lock up Hillary as well there's
nothing to look at in Trump Russia the
same same sort of argument a lot of
people on our subreddit very interested
in the story and I encourage you to
discuss it there with nearly 5,000 other
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
you can find that at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t today's episode of
the david pakman show is made possible
in part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from war
be Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in too I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS